the president of the Motion Picture
Association of America Jack Valenti
I'm really greatly honored to present
nominees these talented nominees for the
documentary sorts short subject some
like my tee times the legacy of Rosa
Parks and Twin Towers have played out
against a background of unquiet history
and others like the collector of Bedford
Street and why can't we be a family
again
unfold in a place where the spotlight
rarely shines in here now are the
nominations for Best Documentary Short
subject
the collector of Bedford Street Alice
Elliott my tea times the legacy of Rosa
Parks Robert Hudson and Bobby Houston
Twin Towers bill guttentag and Robert
David port why can't we be a family
again
Roger Whitesburg and Marie nas oh the
winner is twin towers buildings are
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Robert David
this is the second Academy Award and
fifth nomination for bill guttentag he
won an Oscar
the men are a short subject in 1988 but
you don't have to die
so on September 11 detective Joseph
Viviano
and his brother John made the ultimate
sacrifice for their country
you all have honored them with this
trophy Thank You Mari Povich for
everything thank you Peter Jankowski for
your vision Thank You Alan Berger for
your your guidance and to my wife Lisa
and son Dylan thank you for your love
and support
I'd like to also thank some of the
others who helped make this film Dick
Wolf Lisa and Charles angle dance
Thurman Kate Adler Phil Marshall Michael
Schweitzer no matter where you're from
we're all New Yorkers thank you very
much